beautiful sunrise we've got on this
wednesday morning it is great out there
it feels great because the air is so dry
humidity around 15 percent overall air
quality will be good today but we will
get a little moderate ozone in the
afternoon that's ground level ozone
that's not that's not the good stuff
that protects you from those harmful uv
rays we will have a uv index of eight so
get that sunscreen on you will burn if
you're out there without any protection
for your skin lots of 70s around the
valley this morning clear dry
it just feels good and if you're waiting
for a little cooler weather the weekend
mornings will be in the 60s kind of like
it is out of red rock right now at 65.
kyle canyon's down into the upper 50s
this morning so getting some jacket
weather going in the mountains 102 is
what we're looking for today by the way
that sunrise was 6 23 and sunset at 6 47
so we're getting the equal day equal
night 12 hours of each closer and closer
a week from today
is the arrival of fall mid-90s is where
we should be 107
is the record for today as we take a
look at the coast of the gulf coast wow
it's getting hammered with the flooding
rains from the from nicholas it is a low
pressure system but it's still packing a
lot of potentially deadly flooding and
there are flood warnings that are
already posted into mississippi and
alabama and of course we're worried for
those civilians who are blasting off
from the kennedy space center launch pad
tonight at 802 in the spacex rocket and
there are some thunderstorms in the
forecast about a 50 percent chance
through the day and tonight so fingers
crossed that they blast off safely all
right dry sunny conditions for us a
system moving into the northwest though
will generate some wind for us tomorrow
southwest winds 25 to 30 miles an hour
102 today 100 tomorrow near the century
mark still on friday but the 90s do
arrive by the weekend even mid 90s check
out tuesday this is our last day of
summer whoa 88 degrees mornings in the
60s fall officially arrives just after
lunchtime next wednesday